you're hearing now for the first time
from the man accused of shooting Boston
Red Sox legend David Big Papi Ortiz
Dominican police say Rafi Ferreira Cruz
pulled the trigger at the santo domingo
bar late sunday ortiz was shot at almost
point-blank range new cell phone video
shows him speaking from his holding cell
mul Alinghi has been covering the story
from santo domingo mola what did he say
well Michelle Dominican police say that
role FIFA Dana Cruz confessed to
shooting David Ortiz as part of a nearly
$8,000 hit job but in that cell phone
video that you mentioned fidei de cruz
claims that ortiz was not his intended
target the role FIFA a decree peered
through the barred window of his holding
cell trying to get a message to
reporters it's not David I was confused
he said they only told me the color of
his clothes
Ferreira Cruz said appearing to indicate
he didn't realize it was Ortiz when he
fired the shot Ferreira Cruz is one of
nine suspects detained in connection
with the shooting at the dial bar and
lounge police rushed the suspects to and
from court Thursday running past
reporters as we shouted pleasure they
tossed each of the prisoners into pickup
trucks before jumping in the back
themselves and racing off I mean this is
what they described as a transfer of
prisoners I've never seen anything like
this is more like a rugby scrum
Dominican journalist r-east Beltre says
the shooting has affected the DR greatly
David is beloved here yeah he's a big
puppy here and there back in Boston
Ortiz is still recovering in intensive
care in an Instagram post his daughter
wrote I find myself complaining on a
daily basis but my dad hasn't complained
once
now police here are still looking for at
least one more suspect who's also wanted
back in the u.s. for an attempted
homicide authorities here in the dr have
not said who ordered the hit on one of
the country's most beloved and famous
athletes or why meanwhile the suspects
currently detained are expected to have
a hearing Tony later today
all right Mona thank you very much the Y
is really what people want answer to
this absolutely and who was the intended
target indeed